okay so if you follow the channel in
2020 then you'll know that we talked
about tenet pretty much every other week
and though we thought that we'd picked
the film completely dry of all its
easter eggs having gone back to it i've
found some amazing new details
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down so come with us
protagonist viewer as we go over
everything we unearthed in our latest
viewing now the colors blue and red are
laced throughout the entire film and
these help to let us know whether the
characters are moving forwards or
backwards through time the colors are of
course used heavily in the interrogation
room and they're also present on the
tenor team watches and their armor
beyond that though these colours are
present throughout the film and they
show up in the first few seconds with
the warner brothers logo being red and
the syncope logo being blue cat also
wears a blue dress when the protagonist
meets her and later on in the movie she
wears red when she starts to turn more
and more against her husband during the
high sequence we watch as the
protagonist tries to steal part of the
algorithm and he moves in on a red fire
engine whilst the device itself is
placed onto a blue armored truck he also
rides a blue boat with saturn cat and
turns us against the current hinting
towards the changes in direction that
people later take against the flow of
time when the protagonist waits in the
van with a swat team at the start we see
other vans pull up and you can see their
sirens flashing blue and red on the top
that's probably coincidental but the
badge on the truck is actually red with
blue in the middle of it this badge is
what the protagonist uses when he ends
up infiltrating the opera house and
there's quite another subtle detail here
when we first see the lineup of swat
team members all of their visors are
steamed up due to their breaths whereas
the protagonist isn't this is likely
because he'd only put his masking helmet
on a couple minutes before whereas the
actual swat team had likely had theirs
on whilst riding out to the location
when neil saves his life in this opening
the seat with the reversing bullet is
also blue and when the protagonist runs
out the opera we can see that there's a
big red sign beside him now the train
tracks also have a lot of imagery here
including a big red train that appears
in the scene there are also some moving
forwards on the line whilst the others
move back and this of course foreshadows
how time will be moving in two opposite
directions in the film it's also at this
point that the protagonist takes a
cyanide pill but we later learn it's
actually a dud that works less than i do
watching movies all day come the climax
of the movie we discover that sata has
one of these and he plans to take it
which will in turn stop his heart and
destroy the world look it's complicated
yeah now cat kills him before this can
happen which should potentially mess up
the timeline however there's an
important line that sata drops he says
that he got the pill from the cia and as
we know from the protagonist these don't
actually work therefore even if he did
take it it wouldn't kill him and this is
why cat shooting him doesn't change
anything she was always the person who
was supposed to kill saito and therefore
the pill is just something put in place
by the cia or possibly tenet to make him
feel like he's in control turn it very
much run the entire show and they even
allow the bomb to go off at the end of
the movie so that the past version of
saito will think that he's won and
therefore he'll continue with his plan
thus i do think that the pill was also a
trick by tenet to make sato think that
he actually had a choice when all in all
it was just something supplied by the
cia and the future protagonist there's
also a great line when the protagonist
visits sir michael crosby played by sir
michael kane i'm not sure if that's a
play on his name but he apologizes to
the protagonist for starting dinner
without him the protagonist says that
he'll catch up and this somewhat is a
comment on his character in which he has
to catch up with the operation tenet is
carrying out that started without him
now if you're enjoying the video so far
we'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and also don't forget to subscribe as we
do breakdowns like this every week in
which we talk about all the best hidden
details in movies and tv shows if this
is your first time here then welcome to
the heavy spoiler show i'm your host
paul aka the guy who's never backwards
about coming forwards now let's get into
the rest of the video now things going
backwards and forwards of course is also
shown in the dialogue as a lot of the
characters end up talking backwards when
they're inverted during the highway
chase there's actually a scene in which
we hear sado's men over the radio and
because it's in reverse we can't
understand what they're saying however
huge shout outs to reddit user plot
davis for reversing it so we could see
what sata was telling his men
hussein says that it's in the back of
the sub and this is actually the make of
car that the protagonist ends up driving
after he inverts the algorithm gets
thrown into it and i love the attention
to detail that nolan put into the movie
here there are also several versions in
which we see small glimpses of the
characters coming across versions of
other characters inverted when neil
approaches the turn style at the end of
the movie you can actually catch a small
lone soldier running in the distance
after looking at this closely and
following the path that he goes on i
actually think that this is neil after
he's inverted at the turnstile this area
is somewhere that he'd have to travel
through later and it's so cool seeing
this lone soul jet that he would later
become now one thing that's difficult to
get your head around is that neil
actually never unlocks to get at the end
he is in fact the one who locks it with
christopher nolan creating one of the
biggest head [ __ ] of all time it is a
bit tough to grasp this concept but we
can actually catch him holding the door
open during the scene and it's only when
things have played out enough that he
closes it locks it and then runs back up
the tunnel it's a really good scene and
his goodbye at the end of the movie also
brings a lot with it the protagonist
asks daniel why he isn't with his team
and he says he'll get them on the next
pass meaning that there's also another
version of neil running around in the
final action scene that we don't know
about
didn't your team need you
get them on the next pass
neil asks the protagonist if he's gonna
go to london to check on cat to which
the protagonist says no it's far too
dangerous
i'm going back to london to check on cat
are you no
he's far too dangerous
even from afar
even from afar
this is actually a lie and come the
closing scene of the film we see the
protagonist watching cat from afar which
allows him to catch priya and tie up the
loose ends however the protagonist
always knew that he was going back to
london to check in on cat and he lied to
neil which neil actually seems to get we
can catch him smiling just after he says
this and throughout the film we're told
that ignorance is the strongest weapon
that tenet have in writing nothing down
not knowing anyone's name and also not
keeping any records there's no way that
the people from the future can gain any
information and therefore they can't
warn their forces in the past the
protagonist finally learns to lie here
and it makes neil smirk because he knows
that the protagonist will return to
london and start to see cat for the next
chapter of his life how he knows this
well that could tie into the theory that
neela's actually cat's son which we've
covered in death on another video
that'll be linked at the end but in the
meantime i want to hear what you found
in the movie and if there's any major
hidden details that haven't been
uncovered yet then make sure you leave
them below we are in a competition right
now that will be linked on screen and
all that you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
a quiet place one and two which will be
linked on screen right now we point out
all the cool details in the film that
link across with one another so it's
definitely worth checking out right
after this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
you've been the best i'll see you in the
next one take care peace
bye
oh